كل من يعيش في هذه الارض هو اسد من اسود
الله في الارض والله ورب الكعبه لو قتلتم
كل الرجال ل قاتلتكم صبايا
[موسيقى]
الرمال
هنا كان في وقفه احتجاجيه لمجموعه من
الناس اللي هم الاضعف والافق والابط في
قطع غزه احنا وعدنا في الميدان بانه نكون
مع الناس اللي حابه تعلي صوتها لذلك كنا
موجودين
[موسيقى]
معهم
اسلخ
[موسيقى]
مخ وتب
يتعرب
[موسيقى]
احنا ما دخلنا ديننا الاسلام عشان ناكل
ونشرب ونرقص ونمرق وننزل على التك توك
نتهل احنا في دين الاسلام رجال مجاهدين من
اجل اما النصر واما الشهاده هي احدى
الحسنيين احنا ما خرجنا الا لنصره هذا
[موسيقى]
الدين
صور صور استغل واطلع ترندات بكره بستشهد
وانت بتطلع ترندات وبتصير رحل الذين نحبهم
واوطان اغراض البيت وبعدين ايش بتحط االون
من هنا خش من هذا الشارع ما را
حالون وبعدين ايش حطلي اغنيه في حزن وسع
خلي الناسل ط بكرهها الاغنيه
اللهم اكرمنا يا رب الهاده في سبيلك يا
[تصفيق]
الله